let's look at the solution to a RAS full quiz.
So the question was, is it better to not push anything
anymore once the RAS is full, or simply wrap around
and keep on writing all the addresses with new ones. It
turns out that the wrap around approach is much better
than the don't push approach. To see why, keep in mind
that our program would look like this. We have the main
function that executes for a while, then calls some other function.
This results in pushing something onto the RAS.
Our high-level function here will do a lot of
work, occasionally calling other functions and so on.
We push to see what happens here without running
out of space. Let's say that our RAS
only has two entries. The first entry will be
consumed by pushing the return address when main
calls do it. The second one, will be consumed
when we call the function func from do it. At this
point, we're calling the function dolesss, and it might call, for example,
the add function, many, many times. So, we're getting to the
place where functions are really small. And ideally we would, you know,
push each diamond and pop when we return and so on.
If we only have one entry, then really our entire rest will
be used just when we call do it and as long as
we stay and do it, which might be a very large function
because it might be doing most of the actual work in
the program, all of the function calls that we are doing
really end up being mispredicted because we ran out of ram
space and the one time that we will have a correct
prediction, is when finally return from do it. If we have
two entries, a similar thing will happen. We will consume the
first entry by basically pushing the first thing. So pretty much
we are kind of using an entry here just to save
one missed prediction at the final return. Here again,
we are using the second entry just to save
the return from func, whenever that happens. And func
itself could be calling a lot of functions. So
the don't push approach basically spending entries on kind
of long-term things that need to be remembered so
that we can finally save a misprediction once we
reached the return point from the large function. In contrast,
the wrap around approach is going to push
this, push this, push this thus overwriting this
entry. So now what we are doing, is
we are basically going to be correctly predicting calls
to small functions and returns, and we can
have many of those, in return for inaccurately
predicting the final returns from large functions, because
we have many more small function calls than
large function calls. In the end, we are more
effectively using the few entries we have. Pretty much here,
we are kind of using the entry to save a
misprediction over a very short period of time does this
entry get utilized, and then, it relieves very quickly. Whereas
here we're using an entry for a long time to
save a single misprediction, and in the end we want
to save as many mispredictions as we can. So that's
why the wrap around approach works better
because it ends up correctly predicting causal small
functions, many of which we can have
in return for not correctly predicting the return
from large functions to main, et cetera. Another thing to keep in mind with the
RAS is that it is a predictor, so
either way we will be having some mispredictions.
We are allowed to have mispredictions. All that will happen is
that there will be a branch misprediction. Basically we will fetch the
wrong instructions and have to recover from that. So, in the
end, the discussion about what to do with the RAS, has to
do with achieving a larger number of correct predictions. But neither
of these two ways can actually do things perfectly. So, in the
end we need to just choose which one gives us more correct
predictions, and it turns out that the wrap around approach predicts better
than the don't push approach. While
both of them, result in mispredictions, anyway.